und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend in allen die Züge der
Deutschen Bahn sind heute Vormittag nur
noch maximal 60 Gefahren auf einem
Streckenabschnitt in Niedersachsen das
lag nicht wieso oft an Bauarbeiten oder
einer Signalstörung
es ist eine besondere Form des Gedenkens
immer am dritten Juni
heute genau vor 25 Jahren das schwerste
Zugunglück in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik für immer verbunden mit
dem Namen der Stadt Eschede 101 tote der
dritte juni ist ein schwarzer Tag für
die Eisenbahn heute vor einem Jahr
starben fünf Menschen bei Garmisch und
aus Indien kommen Horrormeldungen über
entzugunglück dort dessen Opferzahl man
immer noch schätzen muss es waren
mindestens
288 dazu Christina kayatz
Hoffnung hier noch Überlebende zu retten
haben die Helfer offenbar nicht mehr mit
schwerem Gerät kämpfen Sie sich jetzt
durch Berge von Stahl und Schrott die
Katastrophe geschah gestern Abend um 19
Uhr Ortszeit für die Passagiere völlig
überraschend
alles ist durcheinander geflogen die
Menschen sind übereinander gestürzt ich
wusste überhaupt nicht was los war dann
ist der ganze Waggon umgekippt und wir
sind irgendwie nach draußen gekommen
etwa 900 Menschen werden verletzt die
Krankenhäuser der Region sind
überfordert denn es sind zu viele der
Platz reicht nicht und die Zahl der
Toten könnte noch weiter steigen auch
Premierminister Modi kommt zum
Unglücksort versucht Trost zu spenden
und verspricht finanzielle Hilfe
wir können den Familien ihre Angehörigen
nicht zurückbringen aber wir sind an
Ihrer Seite
warum genau ist zu dieser Katastrophe
kam ist noch nicht klar offenbar
entgleiste der von Norden kommende
Express gut 200 km südwestlich von
Kalkutta und ein von Süden kommender
Passagierzug raste in die Trümmer war
menschliches Versagen die Ursache
fehlende Sicherheitsstandards Fragen
werden laut sie bleiben heute
unbeantwortet Indien steht unter Schock
und trauert
wir erwarten nicht weitere Überlebende
zu finden sagte örtliche Feuerwehrchef
wir sind entmutigt wir haben noch nie in
unserem Leben so viele Tote gesehen
und jetzt gehen wir mit dem nächsten
Thema weiter und zwar gucken wir da in
die Türkei zwei Zahlen heute die das
Schicksal der Türkei bestimmen mit 52
gut 52 Prozent im Amt bestätigt ist der
alte Präsident auch der neue heute hat
recept type Erdogan seinen Amtszeit
geleistet und geschworen auf seine Ehre
jetzt drückt eine andere Zahl in den
Mittelpunkt bei rund 44% liegt die
Inflation im Land verheerend für viele
Türkinnen und Türken entscheidend wird
jetzt sein ob Erdogan seine umstrittene
Finanz- und Zinspolitik korrigiert Jörg
Brase
Recep Tayyip Erdogan ist und bleibt der
Präsident er nimmt den Parlament die
Ernennungsurkunde für seine dritte
Amtszeit entgegen und den Applaus seiner
Familie und seiner religiös
konservativen Abgeordneten die
Opposition verweigert ihm die Huldigung
die wenigen Vertreter die gekommen sind
bleiben sitzen wütend und stumm
ich schwöre als Präsident all meine
Kraft einzusetzen um die Existenz und
Unabhängigkeit des Staates zu schützen
das Protokoll will es dass das neue
Staatsoberhaupt im Gründer der modernen
Türkei Mustafa Kemal Atatürk die Ehre
erweist Erdogan lenkt heute schon länger
die Regierungsgeschäfte als es Atatürk
Tat beim anschließenden Empfang
beschworen er der vorher im Wahlkampf
das Volk gespalten hatte die Einheit der
Nation
natürlich die Bevölkerung der Türkei
alle 85 Millionen Bürger sollten jetzt
zusammenhalten so wie Ziegelsteine eine
Mauer bilden
[Musik]
angereist aus Brüssel ist
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg der
hofft darauf dass Erdogan den Widerstand
gegen schwedensator Beitritt aufgibt
beobachte halten das für wahrscheinlich
ich denke dass die Türkei der Aufnahme
Schwedens zustimmen wird aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen muss sie den
Fokus auf den Westen legen die Türkei
braucht dringend Investoren
kleine Rand Notiz Deutschlands
ex-fußball Nationalspieler Mesut Özil
saß in der ersten Reihe vermutlich als
treuer Werber um deutsch-türkische
Stimmen für seinen Präsidenten
so und du Hanna hast jetzt die weiteren
wichtigen Nachrichten von heute im
Überblick
Spiegel
hatten noch schon Luftwaffen Offiziere
seit Jahren zur Ausbildung von
chinesischen Kampfpiloten eingesetzt
werden nun hat
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
China aufgefordert das Trainingsprogramm
zu stoppen nach einem Treffen mit seinem
chinesischen Amtskollegen Lee in
Singapur sagte Pistorius dass er
deutlich gemacht habe dass diese Praxis
unverzüglich beendet werden müsse laut
Pistorius habe nie das Vorgehen nicht
bestritten es aber relativiert
mit einem internationalen Abkommen
wollen die UN die Flut von Plastikmüll
auf der Erde eindämmen nach fünf Tagen
gegen Verhandlungen in Paris melden die
Vereinten Nationen nun einen ersten
Fortschritt so haben sich rund 170
Staaten darauf geeinigt bis zur nächsten
Konferenz im November einen
rechtsverbindlichen Entwurf für das
Abkommen vorzulegen darin soll auch die
Entsorgung und das Recycling im Fokus
stehen
Umweltschützer von Greenpeace
kritisierten das Ergebnis als minimal
Kompromiss
zum Sport und damit zu einer großen
Enttäuschung für die Fußballfrauen des
VfL Wolfsburg der deutsche Vizemeister
hat das Finale der Champions League
gegen den FC Barcelona verloren obwohl
es am Ende der ersten Halbzeit noch zwei
zu null für die Wolfsburgerinnen stand
letztendlich konnte der spanische
Meister das Spiel drehen und gewann mit
drei zu zwei
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die
lauten 1 4 6 18 23 30 Superzahl 0 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
so und dann wollten wir heute nach
Leipzig gucken nicht nur neben der
Frankfurter Eintracht beim Fußball
sondern auch auf die Stadt Leipzig wo es
aktuell so Zusammenstößen kommt zwischen
der Polizei und Demonstranten die
linksautonome und linksradikale Szene
hatte ja für heute in Leipzig den
sogenannten Tag X ausgerufen und
tausende Sympathisanten in der Stadt
erwartet aus Solidarität mit einer unter
anderem wegen Gewalttaten Verurteilten
Studentin jetzt bin ich gespannt ob das
funktioniert mit der Schalter nach
Leipzig das müsste uns die Regie jetzt
mal bitte sagen haben wir leider keinen
Kontakt aktuell zu unserem Reporter in
Leipzig dann holen wir das nach in der
nächsten heute Express hier
entschuldigen uns für dieses technische
Problem und gucken jetzt aber doch noch
aufs Wetter
ganz genau bei mir gibt es jetzt die
Wetteraussichten Morgen sehr sonnig an
der Nordsee kann es auch mal mehr Wolken
geben im Tagesverlauf bilden sich im
Süden Quellwolken dazu gibt es an den
Alpen sowie im Südschwarzwald einzelne
Schauer und Gewitter die Temperaturen
liegen bei 15 bis 27 Grad auch in der
nächsten Tagen bleibt es bei dem
sonnigen Wetter mit einzelnen Schauern
und Gewittern im Süden dabei werden 16
bis 28 Grad erreicht
dankeschön fürs Interesse Ihnen einen
angenehmen Abend und außerdem noch viel
Spaß beim Fußball
[Musik]